[Musique]
qui
des petites boules de poils dans tous
les coins du jardin
le refuge nahla shahal ibra réseau
accueille une centaine de chats
abandonnés
une histoire débutée par muriel falot il
y a trois ans j'avais recueilli une
petite chatte qui s'appelait nahla qui
avait sept mois que j'avais fait
stériliser et malheureusement elle a eu
une sorte de kyoto racks donc c'est une
infection fulgurante et elle est décédée
et quand j'étais là voir la clinique
vétérinaire j'étais très triste et je
lui fais une promesse ferme et coutu
sera pas mort pour rien je vais créer
mon association ne portera son nom elle
s'appellera donc nahla
chaque année plus de 100000 chats et
chiens sont abandonnés par leurs maîtres
60% de ces agissements ont lieu pendant
la période estivale dans les parcs et
aires d'autoroute avant les départs en
vacances il y en a beaucoup aussi qui
viennent de de commandes de la fourrière
qui était prêt à être euthanasié et
c'est pour ça que muriel les a pris
c'est quand elle entend le mot
euthanasie elle supporte très mal
surtout ce sont des chats qui sont
adoptables
bien que le refus j'essaye de
sociabiliser tous ces chats certains ils
finiront leur vie
sur les 100 félin actuellement recueilli
une vingtaine seulement c'est dur à une
familles d'adoptants les chats sauvages
craintif ou ou âgées malheureusement
elles ne sont pas adoptables donc il
reste au refuge
on a créé un enclos extérieur de 200
mètres carrés où ils peuvent s'ébattre
rentrer et sortir des chatteries et
voilà on essaie de faire en sorte qu'ils
soient
mazel heureux d'être un petit peu leur
famille puisqu'il n'en auront jamais à
l'adoption sur des personnes qui
seraient vraiment à vouloir faire une
bonne action
et lorsqu'on est une association de
bénévoles il n'est pas toujours évident
de trouver les financements nécessaires
pour payer la stérilisation des chats ou
les soins chez le vétérinaire
alors on a quelques subventions mais
elles sont rares et aussi sur les
adoptions en toute transparence
j'explique aux futurs adoptants qui lie
à une somme qui était gardé pour
stériliser une chatte errante
voilà donc nous ne pratiquons pas les
mêmes tarifs que pour d'autres
fondations
nous sommes un petit peu plus cher
l'état décidé de débloquer 20 millions
d'euros pour agrandir les 800 refuge de
france